lock it in okay this and you're locked
in with me
hopefully they all drop it like the
[ __ ] or something we're going right
now they're jumping yeah three two one
go straight down they wouldn't follow us
maybe hurt I heard more voices coming in
you guys see the l-shaped building yeah
yeah yeah yeah right there all that all
those buildings everyone take a building
okay yeah I don't see any zombies is it
for 1/2 hour southeast pretty close
no we've three with us Oh above us oh
[ __ ] yeah get a gun quickly okay I see
guns on the front porch here right
outside there's tons of them
ah [ __ ] goddamn it goddamn it goddamn
it goddamn oh my god oh my god oh my god
if someone can't help ya I had someone
punch me opium there's one at the
fountain I'm coming towards to you mark
you're right behind me there's one more
I'm [ __ ] down that one's really low
wait that one's really low I'll get you
up I can get you up check brief or short
now there's one more in the grass there
that is that all three of them
yeah I think that might be everyone just
keep an eye out keep an eye out keep an
eye out there was [ __ ] two in my
house
Jesus Christ thank you holy [ __ ] Wow
stick together stick together yeah
word of warning the m16 is only burst
and single yeah do you want am m416 or
whatever it is that yeah yes house full
auto the m416 of this car is the best
one Oh mark where's low one helmet right
yeah I just need a backpack first cuz
I'm all full up okay there was one of
the second-story I level two I believe
okay cool I see it over here if anyone
needs that still okay so I need to four
times no they want to wait backpack
level to in here over to the left I
don't need more [ __ ] I have no
attachments for my scarf we find any
attachments for a scar okay I got a m16
and an S 1897 so pretty pretty weak but
I'll stick with it for now I've got a
hollow so I've got to hollow sites I'm
dropping down here people want to
upgrade their sites there's a zombie in
our compound here in southwest behind
the yellow house they just ran around
the left corner of the LLC alright so I
come and finish them off yeah I'll go
right side and go left I'll stand back
in just in case you guys get flanked or
something I see him he's almost dead
right by you to hit him by
nice who's he down yeah he's down office
oh no threaten not winning he's dead oh
my god
I want a crossbow so hard yeah don't get
too spread out spread out guys I'm just
gonna check this house outside but I'm
gonna aren't there piss wait can you
come with me
there should be pistols can you come
with me wait yeah did anyone check this
big open two-story the register that's
one muscle more can i started in yeah
okay there's pistols in there okay I'm
gonna grab one just so I have another
gun okay what guns do everyone have I've
got a shotgun and wait there's a pistol
right here man I guess I got one okay
I'm heading back downstairs that were
you're at bub Jack and I are downstairs
yeah no one outside that I can see we're
actually right on the edge of the circle
too which is nice yeah we won't have a
foregrip for a scar no okay we could
check this other out house outside the
compound this one on the hill I'm a huge
difference all right I'm with Jack over
here someone search this building as
this doors open yeah I Stark was yeah
yeah all right well you guys find a for
groups let me know I'm with Jack just so
we're not split up yeah I'm just gonna
watch marks back yeah think we want to
be heading to poach inky or school I
think they all assembled at school I
think they all went to school yeah yeah
but [ __ ] is where the circle and all
right we're clear here that's all
there's no really good in here pretty
let's head back to them oh wait I'm good
this one more frag okay yeah I'm full
like literally can't carry anything so
we're heading to blue okay we're
following we're behind you guys we
should keep moving
three Oh we had 97 I think when we came
in so unless some dropped out we killed
more yeah we killed a good number it was
a solid five or six maybe yeah I wasn't
there for a lot of it so I kind of
missed out
I saw one drop the drop ahead of us at
210
we should come left and get that it
actually come out it's on the ground
sitting there already it's not even
smoking any well
watch.watch approaching it for zombies
camping it movement it's unlike that box
sitting right there in the opening
weights running right for it watch watch
out for four campers around it just make
sure approach slowly and have your
shotguns ready and then it's if it's not
like an m249 or like a tommy gun I don't
even think we want it at this point [ __ ]
son so now now go to blue yeah yeah I
don't see any movement up in place I've
been watching like fine I'll wait for
you yeah new circle if you want like a
hollow side I've got one you can have
for that thing no no I just got one nope
movement ahead maybe I can't tell from
the Flies around here I keep thinking
bees which surprises me cuz I do not
scream like you know three backpack out
here I really need a level three bag if
anyone else doesn't I'm good it gets
three energy drinks that's not bad yeah
I'm good on that there's some bandages
on my crap one of these never mind I
can't grab any advantages well I don't
know that well time to use bandages
anyway but there's bandages there yeah I
feel like II might as well just hold it
out oh there's like an assload of
first-aid kits in here galore there's a
level three helmet on me oh I need that
somehow I don't have a helmet Oh
as well Oh mark beat me - oh I'm sorry
I'm sorry there's level twos though
there's two level two he's right here
I'm good quick draw for Narn s12
I've got a quick draw prefer to fund an
extended mag I do need a tactical error
for it not a technical for grade oh yeah
folks to your boy zombie inside I
thought I heard two voices though yep I
did I'm out there how dare they try to
eat your eyes all right I'm falling up
right behind you
yeah I'm just baiting a little bit they
probably got spooked away don't push too
far out let's just as a for 9m oh
there's more 5 5 6 right here anyone
have any way what ammo does the 2 4 9
take 5 5 6 5 6 right here I need that
don't wait yes no okay
I'm dropping my 7 6 - ammo for that if
someone needs a 7 6 - there's guys
there's two more level three helmets
right here oh and there's one up on top
Oh Jack don't forget I'm standing he was
silver yeah all right all right I think
we're pretty much fully loaded guys we
should just get in the circle and start
to find the next place we're gonna spend
some time I see they reduced damage I
don't know how much but they do reduce
damage if you were if you were naked and
you just took a punch from azam azam be
with maxed out damage melee damage it to
the face you would be down in one shot
Oh so the fact that we weren't getting
one shot it well in the last couple
rounds when they were coming up and
scooping us means that they was reducing
the damage by some amount I think that
level three vest made a big difference
it took them like six or seven yeah
dropped
I'm gonna come with you oh that's a
little ways away though man I mean
where's our one closer archive in the
building next to you okay
I just exited the building so I'm gonna
watch you way out wait your voice I
don't have voice on so maybe it's not
I'm going for Jackie's alone so I think
I'm so scared for to see the Horde I
know I wish I wish I had some sense of
where they are cuz you know somewhere
there's a bunch of them we're all on
that Ridge right there oh no oh that's
I just wanna hear like a big old zombie
roar I don't I don't want to hear any of
that I'll go home I wish that there was
more violence I wish they could like
take down structures and so you could be
like in a building and it was just like
good like the house is gonna collapse
like yeah that that would that would not
that this needs more terror but that
would be [ __ ] terror yeah but why the
hell would you go there aren't doors on
them so it's like there's no reason for
them to do that they could just walk
around and kill the [ __ ] out of you
you will never see the whole your
tiredness is slipped away
yeah I'm pretty any adrenalin I have in
my body is being used up for this for
them to like just pop up out of the
grass as we run by and be like yeah I
don't want that we need to thin that
herds we're going to blue well there is
a jeep we might actually want that just
as a way to get the [ __ ] out of place
this way more of this building was
either blown open by bombs or punched
open
point wheels Oh change rising [ __ ] you
were right zombies why you can always
guard tower
really uncomfortable no back ourselves
into a corner from which there's no
escape hell yeah good god I don't think
I could take it but I'll try something
I'm just gonna take puppy's painkillers
just take it and take the energy drink
and then you'll be fully stocked okay on
the table bye jack yeah it's not take up
Africa [ __ ] it I'm not gonna take up any
more time yeah it's in it's right there
no it's too late man right we know there
were a bunch of them northwest of us I
can't wait to see them come pouring down
the hill toward us single shot just just
so I can have a little bit of control
like the control but the same time it is
like a mass amount of them just drop us
my land right at us oh well that's
telegraphing unless it dropped already
we got a we have two minutes I'm not
worried about the time I'm worried about
the Yemenis follow us want to follow
this road this is this is a bad place
for last end they can come from
everywhere there's a tiny circle in 80
80 80 will the direction that we saw
them on the ridge we have to fight him
at some point wait here drop right here
drop right here okay there's no hope in
these drops but at least we can feel
comfortable somewhere to go that drops
only happen in the white circles oh oh I
don't like going over the top of these
hills where we can't see what's coming
this is stress oh no Oh someone finally
bled out that sucks
someone we killed a lot downed a long
time ago just finally died I got a bad
feeling about there's too many zombies
alive frost ball is [ __ ] circulating
no I got it does it make sense oh well
that's that's the that's the chime
dinner bell ding ding ding there another
one to the left there at the drop right
here where I'm facing make sure we watch
all directions we're good a direction
way to pick a direction okay you keep
running into me and looking the same way
as me I just don't want to still get
punched from behind all right I'll look
in this thing real quick smart Magnum
there's an awm a ghillie suit behind me
Bob oh yeah somebody could get the
ghillie suit and like become invisible
go for it Oh lots of them lots of them
guys come up the hill towards us contact
come hey doubt there's wonder where I am
yeah we killed someone
that was there coming up from behind
really really fast guys yeah we got a
ton of contact
oh boy let's go let's go let's go just
run into the circle and down oh boy yeah
go go into the circle right now thanks
alright time to go huh
I'm coming I've got a lot behind me yeah
me too I've got a lot in front of me
I've got a lot of them everywhere run
marks the safest right there's somebody
behind you on the hill way they could
all I got this so six of them all around
you oh boy oh boy oh boy I don't I can't
reload I guess I could switch to my
other gun when you guys have healed so
on your own oh whoa switched another gun
you [ __ ] oh boy oh boy
and he'll what they'll they'll they'll
don't die immediately oh no what have
heals but you do
cool news or is the only thing you oh oh
no oh that's are we going out to play
zone
[Music]